we got to do more bits from city council
meetings Benjy once did a good one
this was Benjy at his best when he Benjy
went down to Port Authority there was a
few having a hearing there having a
hearing on toll hikes and Benjy did the
speech from Footloose at the end when
the kids demand to be able to dance
because there's been a ban on dancing
from the oldest of times people who
danced for a number of reasons they
dance to prayer or so that their crops
this is proof that no one listens at
these meetings because this has nothing
to do with toll hikes and they dance to
stay and show and it danced to celebrate
they don't even shut Benjy down in
Samuel the good news was the City
Council voted and they allow Benjy to
dance and Benjy could use some dancing
trust me with all his might and even
know Benjy was a Footloose fan
Ecclesiastes assures us went on please
yes Abbey's suffering succotash ecclesia
fatigue that there's a time for every
purpose under heaven a time to laugh and
a time to weep a time to mourn and there
is a time to dance right and there was a
time for this law but not anymore see
this is our time to dance our way of of
celebrating life no one's like catching
on we were expecting he be interrupted
speech it's the way it's always been
it's the way should be now
amen you people like it you got all the
way through it awesome